Es hora de que empecemos a innovar
en donde nadie está innovando todavía:
el sistema político.
Porque nuestra democracia
está terriblemente estancada
y ya no es capaz de responder
a las demandas de una sociedad
que se complejiza cada vez más
y se transforma de la mano
de las nuevas tecnologías.
Trabajar en política no es fácil.
Yo, de hecho, empecé mi vida
en el mundo de la sociedad civil.
Pero yo creo que necesitamos
distribuir mejor el poder,
compartir el conocimiento
y encontrar espacios de diálogo
que nos permitan llegar
a mejores soluciones con más consenso.
Y la política es la mejor herramienta
que tenemos para hacerlo.
Entonces, hace un par de años,
decidí dar el salto de fe
y empecé a trabajar
en una campaña electoral
en la provincia de Buenos Aires.
Y lo que vi no me gustó nada de nada.
Primero: nadie discutía ideas.
De lo único que se discutía
era de personas.
Yo me acuerdo una vuelta
veía cómo le borraban los bigotes
y le blanqueaban lo dientes con Photoshop
a un candidato
porque tenía que parecer joven.
No importaba que sus ideas
fueran del siglo pasado.
Lo único que importaba era aparentar.
Una vuelta me encontré
en un galpón municipal
en el conurbano
de la provincia de Buenos Aires.
Tenía stockeado
hasta acá chapas, colchones,
materiales de construcción sin repartir.
Cuando yo pregunto qué hacía
todo eso ahí, por qué no lo repartían,
me contestan con una frescura terrible:
"¿No te das cuenta?
Lo guardamos para el año que viene,
para las elecciones".
Claro. Ese año no había elecciones.
La gente no votaba,
¿qué importaba que no tuviera techo
o no tuviera un lugar donde dormir?
Si total, ese año no se la consultaba.
Y ese es el problema.
Nosotros vivimos en un sistema político
que responde a una tecnología
de la información de hace 400 años:
de la imprenta.
Cuando los que eran
considerados ciudadanos
ya no podían participar de los espacios
en donde se tomaban las decisiones
y tampoco tenían el acceso
a la información necesaria para tomarlas.
Entonces lo que se diseñó
fue un sistema basado en intermediarios.
Los representantes son intermediarios
entre los ciudadanos
y aquellos espacios en donde se tomaban
las decisiones que impactaban en su vida.
Y es la misma democracia
que tenemos hoy en día.
Pero la sociedad cambió.
Miren esto.
Esta es la asunción del Papa en el 2005
y la misma foto en el 2013.
Hoy si queremos enterarnos
de cualquier tema,
no tenemos más que meternos en Wikipedia
o incluso podemos buscar
alguna TED al respecto.
¿Quién no se enteró primero
por un usuario de Twitter
sobre algún suceso en cualquier
lugar del mundo,
antes que por un medio tradicional
de comunicación?
¿Quién no posteó alguna vez o vio posteado
"Estoy buscando un colaborador",
"Este es mi curriculum",
"Necesito un departamento para alquilar"?
Hoy es más probable
que encontremos trabajo
a través de LinkedIn,
que a través de una agencia
y un departamento a través de Facebook
que a través de una inmobiliaria.
Y ni que hablar de cómo la conectividad
transformó la industria de la cultura
y el entretenimiento.
Está cambiando incluso nuestra
percepción sobre la propiedad.
Hoy, ¿queremos tener el CD físico
o lo que queremos es escuchar la música?
¿Queremos tener el DVD
archivado en la biblioteca
o lo que queremos es poder ver
la película?
Internet lo que hace es que
baja radicalmente
las barreras de acceso a la información
y nos transforma a todos nosotros
en productores-consumidores
de información.
Internet nos permite estructurarnos
de par a par, sin intermediarios,
y todos podemos participar virtualmente
de la gran conversación global.
Internet transformó esa conversación
que era de pocos a muchos
a una conversación de muchos a muchos,
la democratizó.
Y esto lo estamos viendo
en todos los ámbitos:
en la cultura, en la educación,
en la organización del trabajo,
en lo social, incluso en la economía.
Pero, ¿y la política?
El sistema político insiste
en excluirnos de los espacios
en donde se toman las decisiones.
Y la consecuencia en todo el mundo,
es esta.
[Error 404. Democracia no encontrada]
Es un choque entre un sistema
que ya no representa
y no tiene capacidad de diálogo
y un montón de ciudadanos
que estamos cada vez más acostumbrados
a representarnos a nosotros mismos,
sin intermediarios.
Miren.
Occupy Wall Street,
los indignados españoles,
los estudiantes chilenos,
la Primavera Árabe,
son todos ejemplos de esta crisis
global de representación.
Yo veía todo este vapor que la válvula
del sistema político
que tenemos ya no contiene,
y la pregunta que no podía
evitar hacerme es:
¿cómo vamos a hacer para pasar
de la agitación a la construcción?
Porque parece que podemos usar
las redes sociales
para, a un costo muy bajo,
organizarnos para
grandes movilizaciones masivas.
Pero lo que no discutimos
es qué queremos hacer después.
¿Qué instituciones queremos construir
para esta nueva sociedad en red?
Entonces si Internet es la nueva imprenta,
la pregunta que nos tenemos
que hacer es esta:
¿Cuál es la democracia
de la era de Internet?
Entonces con un grupo de personas
armamos acá, en Argentina,
una fundación que se llama
Democracia en Red.
Y tiene como objetivo pensar
cómo podemos hacer
para transformar todo este ruido
en señal que tenga
llegada directa al sistema.
Y empezamos a ver un montón
de ejemplos en todo el mundo
y decidimos crear una instancia nueva
de participación ciudadana
y de pensamiento social
para las legislaturas locales.
La pregunta que nos motivaba
es cómo podíamos aprovechar
esta nueva tecnología que estábamos viendo
para hacer que nuestros
representantes representen.
Hay dos razones
por las cuales elegimos este camino.
La primera es porque nosotros creemos
que los costos para la participación
son demasiado altos.
Si participar en política significa
militar todos los días
desde la universidad
para alguna vez, tal vez,
sentarse en alguna mesa de algún partido
que tome alguna decisión...
Si participar en política significa
poner una mesa en una esquina,
salir a juntar 4000 firmas,
y armar un proyecto de ley
para después esperar
que nuestros legisladores
le presten atención...
Si participar en política significa
tener que ser abogado
para entender de qué se tratan las leyes
que están regulando nuestra vida...
Bueno, entonces claramente van a ser
los menos los que van a querer participar.
Pero, ¿qué pasa si se lo hacemos
más fácil al ciudadano?
¿Qué pasa si podemos crear un espacio
en donde incluso aquellos que solamente
tienen una hora por semana
pero les importan los temas de su ciudad
y tienen algo para decir
lo puedan hacer?
La segunda razón
por la cual elegimos este camino,
es porque nosotros creemos
que llegamos a mejores decisiones
escuchando la mayor cantidad
de voces posible.
Entonces, ¿por qué pensamos
que un legislador decidiendo solo
va a poder comprender mejor
todas las aristas
que significan diseñar
un proyecto de ley e implementarlo
que si lo hace en conjunto
con aquellos que son directamente
afectados por esa ley?
Ahora, ¿cómo hacemos para meter
100 000 ideas en una banca?
¿Cómo hacemos para que un legislador
encarne todas esas posturas diferentes?
Bueno, de vuelta, aprovechemos
la tecnología y exploremos ese camino.
Y entonces el sistema que diseñamos
tiene dos componentes.
Se llama Democracia OS.
Un componente online
y un componente offline.
El componente online es una red social
para la participación democrática.
Es una plataforma web
que nos va a permitir
informarnos, debatir y votar
cómo queremos que voten
nuestros legisladores.
Informarnos es clave.
Les voy a leer ahora una ley, de hecho.
No es un proyecto, es una ley.
"Desaféctese del distrito
de zonificación urbanización futura UF
del código de planeamiento urbano
las fracciones C y H de la manzana 75A,
sección 92, circunscripción 1
y aféctese a distrito U, urbaniza..."
Bueno... me entienden.
No es chiste. Esto es así.
Esto quiere decir que van a cambiar
la zonificación de dos manzanas
para que ahí se puedan hacer torres.
Bueno. Cambia la cosa.
Si supiéramos que en la esquina
de casa van a hacer una torre,
¿no tendríamos algo para decir?
No sé, por ahí estamos de acuerdo.
O por ahí no.
Pero si no nos informamos,
si no nos enteramos
nunca vamos a poder opinar.
Entonces, lo primero que vamos a hacer
es listar todos los proyectos de ley
que están hoy en discusión
y los vamos a explicar
para que todos los podamos entender.
Y ahora, una vez que nos enteramos,
que nos informamos y tenemos una opinión,
¿qué pasa hoy con todas esas opiniones?
¿Mueren en una charla de café?
¿O hacen su camino a los comentarios
de un diario online?
Pero, ¿qué pasa si nosotros
podemos crear un espacio
que estructure todas esas opiniones?
En donde se debatan,
en donde esas ideas
terminen en proyectos de ley
que realmente representen
a nuestra comunidad.
En donde, si uno está cómodo
con un determinado tema, pueda votar,
pero si no está cómodo
pueda delegar ese voto
en otra persona en la cual confía,
pero para ese tema en particular,
no ya por dos años enteros.
¿No les interesaría participar
de un espacio así?
Hoy, ¿qué opciones nos da el sistema
para participar?
Una audiencia pública,
un martes a las once de la mañana
en pleno Microcentro.
¿Quiénes de acá pueden estar a las once
de la mañana en el Microcentro un martes
para poder emitir una opinión?
¿Por qué tenemos que seguir participando
físicamente de estos espacios?
Y esa es nuestra única alternativa.
Nosotros hoy podemos estudiar
en un curso a distancia
de una universidad
que nunca vamos a ver en la vida,
podemos intentar financiarnos
con microdonaciones
de gente de todo el mundo,
trabajamos en red con gente
que probablemente nunca vayamos a conocer,
¿pero no le podemos decir
a nuestro legislador
si queremos enrejar o no
la plaza de la esquina de casa?
Bueno, no parece tener mucho sentido, ¿no?
Y acá es donde entra este componente
offline que es fundamental,
que son los partidos políticos.
¿Y por qué es fundamental?
Porque en Argentina
el monopolio de la representación
lo tienen los partidos políticos.
La única manera que nosotros tenemos
de llevar esta inteligencia colectiva
y que tenga impacto directo en el sistema
es a través de partidos políticos
que se presenten a elecciones,
que ganen bancas
y que se comprometan a votar de acuerdo
a lo que se decida en esta plataforma.
Imagínense a un legislador
que va a las reuniones de comisión
y las filma para que todos lo podamos ver.
O imagínense a ese legislador que discute
en un foro online los domingos
con todos los ciudadanos.
No es imposible.
No es mandar una misión a la Luna,
las herramientas están.
Entonces, la plataforma
que nosotros creamos
es de código abierto y libre
porque lo que necesitamos
son partidos políticos que se animen
a cambiar la lógica a través
de la cual toman las decisiones.
Que dejen de hacerlo de espaldas
a la ciudadanía y lo empiecen a hacer
con aquellos a quienes están afectando
directamente con esas decisiones,
que somos todos nosotros.
Imagínense todo lo que podemos hacer
si nosotros nos animamos a innovar
en donde nadie innova todavía,
en el sistema político.
Todo lo que podemos lograr.
Marshall McLuhan dice que la política
es resolver los problemas de hoy
con las herramientas de ayer.
Bueno, es hora de que resolvamos
los problemas de hoy
con las herramientas de hoy.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.